[Music]
so in Europe we're fascinators with your
election Hillary and Trump goodness and
everybody that you talk to says well how
is Trump being so successful why on
earth are people tolerating sexist
racist hate speech and there's a good
answer for it I wrote a piece recently
for time and I discussed why Trump is
having the sort of success that he's
having at the moment and it comes down
to one thing Trump is a troll that has
jumped off the internet and into the
real world and the reason that so many
people are tolerant of his extreme
statements is name-calling this horrible
nasty even the sadistic behavior is
because the online environment has
normalized this type of behavior in
cybersecurity we point out that what
happens in the cyber world impacts on
the real world what happens in the real
world impacts on the cyber world and
this is certainly true in terms of
Trump's behavior there's a great study
titled trolls just want to have fun and
you should read us because it talks
about the dark tetrad of personality the
study found that people who say that
they like to troll
actually score high on an an index that
measures machiavellianism an index that
measures psychopathic traits and index
it measures narcissistic traits and
sadism and the study found that trolling
was a manifest
station of everyday sadism and election
aside I know it's important but I'm more
concerned about a bigger issue the issue
is that people like me spend our time
trying to teach kids to be nice to each
other online but it's very hard for us
to win that battle when politicians use
cruelty and sadism as a strategy and
appear to gain ground because of it so
cyberspace is an environment it's
somewhere where you go it's an immersive
environment chat room forum took place
and what happens there is that behavior
can become normalized so as human beings
we're social creatures and we learn from
others so if appears that everybody is
doing something it can seem that it's
okay and it's become very difficult with
the pervasive penetration and
accessibility of the Internet to draw
the line between something that's an
evolving behavior and that's become
almost a social norm and sadly online
trolling has become almost a social norm
the problem is when that behavior cyber
migrates into the real world and Trump
and the way he behaves is a classic
example of cyber migration
[Music]